Hi ihr Lieben oder soll ich lieber sagen "Merhaba, Hoş geldiniz"?
Weil wir machen heute was türkisches. Ihr habt nämlich gesagt "Kiki Mensch, mach doch mal wieder irgendwas
türkisches!" und das hab ich mir zu Herzen genommen
und heute gibt's die besten Köfte, die ihr je gegessen habt!
(H: Besser als in Istanbul?)
Besser als in Istanbul!
Wir haben ja in Istanbul bei einem ganz bekannten Restaurant..wie hieß es jetzt nochmal Hamza, weißt du das?
(H: Irgendwas mit K, ich weiß es auch nicht mehr)
Köftecisi...Yusuflar Köftecisi? Auf jeden Fall mega bekanntes Restaurant, da haben wir gegessen
und da hab ich mir gedacht: Hey, die schmecken genau
(H: Das war Yusuf abi!)
Der Yusuf abi!
Das hat genauso geschmeckt! Also wirklich bei mir in der Küche hat's genauso gut geschmeckt
und das Rezept teil ich jetzt mit euch weil das echt ein spezielles Rezept ist mit 2 ganz speziellen Zutaten,
die ich euch hier bereitgestellt hab.
Wir benötigen natürlich Rinderhackfleisch. Hier hab ich jetzt zufällig das fettarme,
ihr könnt aber natürlich das fettreiche Rinderhackfleisch nehmen.
Dann hab ich an Gewürzen gemahlenen Kreuzkümmel, Paprikaflocken(die sind scharf) und Paprikapulver edelsüß.
Hier vorne hab ich noch Paniermehl für die Bindung, hier ist die erste Geheimzutat, nämlich Backpulver.
Dann haben wir hier geriebene Zwiebeln, die zweite Geheimzutat: Mineralwasser mit Kohlensäure, ganz, ganz wichtig!
und natürlich Salz und Pfeffer.
Die Hackfleischmasse vorzubereiten ist total easy. Wir geben jetzt alle Zutaten, die euch eben gezeigt habe,
mit zum Fleisch und dann knetet ihr das mit den Händen 5-7min lang.
Also den Tipp mit dem Mineralwasser hab ich von meiner Tante aus Izmir, die macht
nämlich die besten Köfte weltweit. Und die hat mir gesagt: "Kiki, mach Mineralwasser
rein, vertrau mir das macht das Ganze so ein bisschen fluffiger."
(H: Ach wie bei Eiern ist das dann?)
Wie bei Rührei, da macht man ja auch manchmal ein bisschen Mineralwasser
mit Kohlensäure rein. Und so macht ihr das eben auch bei den Köfte.
Und das Backpulver, das ist so ein kleiner Geheimtipp. Das verändert so ein bisschen die Konsistenz,
also ich kann euch das so ein bisschen schwer erklären, ihr müsst's einfach mal ausprobieren.
Das macht's so ein bisschen fluffiger. Klar, Backpulver ist ja dafür da, dass etwas aufgeht
gleichzeitig aber auch so ein bisschen krosser.
(H: Fast schon crunchy eigentlich)
Ja ich weiß nicht, man kann's nicht beschreiben! Außen sind die Köfte so wirklich,
die haben so eine gaaanz zarte, leichte Kruste und innen sind sie total weich.
(H: Total weich.)
Schwierig zu erklären, ihr müsst es ausprobieren. Also das ist jetzt die fertige Masse.
Ihr könnt's jetzt entweder in den Kühlschrank nochmal geben, damit die Gewürze nochmal schön einziehen
falls ihr's jetzt ein bisschen mehr Zeit habt, dann gebt's einfach für 1/2h in den Kühlschrank.
Wenn ihr keine Zeit habt so wie wir weil wir haben nämlich Hunger,
deswegen red ich jetzt auch grad so ein bisschen schneller, dann einfach direkt weiterverarbeiten.
Und ich hab jetzt hier noch einen Tipp für euch: Ihr könnt euch jetzt die Hände ein bisschen nass machen,
ich hab hier ne Schüssel mit Wasser. EInfach nass machen und dann formen.
So auf mein mit Backpapier ausgelegtes Backblech kommt jetzt noch ein bisschen Öl
damit auch nichts haften bleibt.
So jetzt gebt ihr die fertig vorbereiteten Köfte in den vorgeheizten Backofen.
Ich heiz ihn immer vor auf 210 Grad Ober- und Unterhitze.
Und dann müsst ihr einfach schauen, sind die jetzt dicker oder dünner?
Kleiner Tipp, macht's lieber dünner, die gehen noch ein bisschen hoch im Ofen.
Und dann müsst ihr einfach schauen wann sie durch sind. Meine genaue Minutenzahl
notiert der Hamza euch hier.
Hast du doch bestimmt gemacht, ne?
(H: Ja natürlich hab ich das gemacht!)
Sehr gut! Also bis nachher!
So das Geniale ist: das hab ich euch noch garnicht verraten, ihr könnt dieses Köfte Rezept
entweder im Ofen zubereiten oder in der Pfanne oder auf dem Grill!
Also ein richtiger Allrounder! Das heißt ihr habt immer das perfekte Köfte Rezept und speichert das euch ab,
macht's unbedingt nach und wenn ihr jetzt noch nen Tipp haben möchtet,
was dazu passt:
also türkischer Reis, der passt definitv dazu. Das Rezept haben wir auch noch für euch abgefilmt,
verlink ich euch in die Infobox. Und jetzt ist das natürlich ein bisschen..nicht trocken in dem Sinne,
sondern man braucht immer was zum Dippen oder ne Soße dabei
und da mach ich ganz gerne Paprikasoße, die geht so easy, Leute!
Ihr nehmt einfach Öl, bratet darin Paprikamark an, gebt Paprikapulver und Minze dazu(gerne getrocknete Minze)
löscht das Ganze mit gekochtem Wasser ab, salzen und fertig.
Und das ist die fertige Soße, richtig perfekt.
Also die passt 1A!
Und dann hab ich noch nen Tipp für euch: reicht gerne Joghurt dazu, das passt auch optimal.
Ihr nehmt einfach fettarmen Joghurt zum Beispiel, Knoblauch, Salz und fertig.
Mehr braucht es nicht und ihr habt ein richtig schönes Mittag- oder Abendessen!
So meine Lieben, ich weiß, dass ihr jetzt alle wild darauf seid, die Köfte in der Küche nachzumachen
also ganz viel Freude beim Nachmachen!
Guten Appetit!
Hinterlasst dem Video auf jeden Fall ein Däumchen nach oben, wenn ihr bis hierhin geschaut habt.
Und ganz ganz wichtig, falls ihr noch kein Abonnent meines Kanals seid: ganz schnell nachholen!
Dann bekommt ihr halt immer mit, wenn hier mal ein neues Video online geht.
Und ansonsten lasst uns doch gerne in den Kommentaren noch miteinander schreiben.
Ihr wisst ja, es ist ja immer so, dieses Rezept ist ja jetzt auch durch euch entstanden
weil ihr gesagt habt: "Kiki, mehr türkische Rezepte!" und da sind sie!
Und daher schreibt mir gerne hier unten rein, was ihr noch so sehen möchtet.
Also ich liebe es ja, rund um den Globus zu kochen!
Und dann würd ich mal sagen, sehen wir uns in meinem nächsten Rezeptvideo!
Ciao!
Hoşçakalın!
Hamza, jetzt musst du das auch nochmal sagen!
(H: Hoşçakalın!)
(H: War doch richtig!)
Ja aber aus deinem Mund ist das immer so witzig!